vienen más ataques dentro de Rusia así
lo anunció el comandante de una de las
milicias de ultraderecha opuestas a
Vladimir Putin en una declaración a la
prensa hecha desde una ubicación
desconocida en medio del campo de
batalla son dos grupos que están en
contra de la operación militar ordenada
por Vladimir Putin en Ucrania en febrero
de 2022 y que han expresado su
inconformidad con ataques a la provincia
fronteriza de virgoroth el más reciente
una operación con drones en la madrugada
del miércoles el grupo menciona que fue
parte de la fase 1 de una escalada que
apenas comienza
la operación está en curso Así es como
debería decirlo para ser honesto
definitivamente tiene diferentes fases
así la fase 1 que consideramos un éxito
ya terminado pero la operación está en
curso
por otro lado el líder de otra milicia
privada jeffre fundador del grupo Wagner
hizo un recuento del actuar de su
organización en la lucha por la ciudad
de bahamut y remarcó que el objetivo del
kremlin por desmilitarizar Ucrania no
fue cumplido
si al principio de la operación militar
especial tenían digamos 500 tanques
ahora tienen 5000 si tenían 20.000
hombres para luchar ahora tienen 400.000
cómo los hemos desmilitarizado resulta
que es al revés lo hemos militarizado
el grupo de voluntarios rusos y la
legión por la libertad de Rusia son los
dos grupos que se han atribuido los
ataques el primero fundado por un
político ruso neonazi exiliado en
Alemania ambos se componen mayormente de
Nacionales rusos que pelean en el bando
ucraniano y tienen como objetivo acabar
con el gobierno de Vladimir Putin